[Musique]
mon père est un bon soir au sommaire de
ce magazine des animaux du monde je vous
propose aujourd'hui un gros plan sur les
lévriers de course avec le docteur
pierre rous les blancs un reportage sur
la fosse aux serpents du zoo de
doué-la-fontaine un nouveau livre l'asie
présenté par son auteur pierre fait
faire et pour commencer bien sûr
l'actualité animale commenté par jean
michel hermant au kenya on a trouvé une
nouvelle méthode pour neutraliser les
anti ben l'hélicoptère l'hélicoptère
survole la savane à basse attitude
repère les troupeaux et les pousse vers
des emplois
il ne s'agit nullement d'une chasse mais
d'une transplantation en afrique
l'antilope est une espèce en voie de
disparition de plus la région de thies
cas où elles vivent vient d'être promise
un développement industriel et agricole
c'est donc pour les sauver que les
antilopes sont capturés et sont
acheminés par camion vers des réserves
comme celle de simba us
[Musique]
la marine américaine recherche pour les
naufragés des moyens de protection
contre les requins à san diego en
californie elle expérimente de méthode
la première consiste à planter une
flèche électrifié sur le requin les
muscles du squale se paralyse et
l'animal demeure immobile jusqu'à ce que
l'intensité du courant soit nul
la seconde expérience nécessite
également une pêche muni d'un petit
parachute effrayé par ce dernier leur
cas ne pense qu'à une chose s'en
débarrasser ainsi ils ne s'intéressent
plus à ceux qui l'environnent les
américains comme à une époque les
australiens connaissent à leur tour un
surpeuplement de la pâte notamment dans
l'état du dao les lapins sont devenus
une véritable calamité pour les cultures
et les chasseurs ne sont pas assez
nombreux pour les déciment
mais comment tout américain il ya un
businessman qui sommeille on a trouvé
une solution créer un surplus de lapin
les rongeurs sont donc capturer sur une
échelle industrielle
ils sont triés sélectionnés en pack très
vivant et vendu de dollars soit environ
11 30 pièces à des sociétés de chasse
italienne qui en manquent
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que l'an passé dès
l'ouverture les chasseurs italiens ont
pu tirer sur plus de 500 milles ap un
américain
mais attention à ceux qui survivent ils
se reproduisent à grande vitesse et
demain l'italie peut connaître les mêmes
inconvénients que l'amérique et
l'australie
[Musique]
pour finir encore une chasse mais cette
fois du gros gibier
l'éléphant sauvage cela se passe en inde
dans l'état de 8 en or
mais là la tradition l'exigent on ne
chasse pas l'éléphant pour le tuer mais
pour le domestique et comme chacun sait
en inde la richesse vient souvent du
travail accompli par le pachyderme ici
la chasse se déroule dans la forêt de
kara pour plusieurs dizaines d'hectares
sont en cours et par les rabatteurs qui
au moyen de tambours et de coups de
fusil tous les éléphants sauvages vers
un piège
ce piège est un périmètre boisé clos par
de solides barrières
après quelques jours d'acclimatation on
commence la domestication et le dressage
qui se révèle d'ailleurs assez facile
cette chasse à l'éléphant sauvage fait
souvent partie des attractions
touristiques proposés par la haine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lors du dernier magazine nous avons
représenté les lévriers ces aristocrates
du monde can am et puis à voter blanc il
existe d'autres races de lévriers qui se
soucie peut être moins de beauté que
d'efficacité je veux parler des crane dd
oui parce qu'ils sont tous même les
champions incontestés de vitesse cure
je ne sais pas si souci de booster mon
hockey ils sont très beaux effectivement
ce sont des animaux de sport que nous
allons vous présenter aujourd'hui nous
avons réuni trois races sur le plateau
nous parlons de sport mais il faut pas
oublier que ces chiens étaient des
animaux à l'origine de chasse et
notamment en egypte et au surtout au
moyen âge où ils connurent leur apogée
et on fut même obligé d'interdire cette
chasse en france tellement ces animaux
faisait des gars ont interdit cette
chasse en 1844 je crois oui c'était
tellement rapide qu'il laissait aucune
chance
absolument aucune chance alors à tout
seigneur tout honneur le grès hard en
garde on pourrait dire que c'est le pur
sang le pur-sang de lévriers c'est un un
animal qui comme pour tous les frais
liés à une origine ancienne il provient
soudan haute egypte mais c'est un e-mail
qui a été définie de manière absolument
remarquable par un dicton du 15e siècle
anglais qu'on pourrait traduire comme
ceux ci la tête d'un serpent le coût
d'un canard les pieds comme un chat la
queue de rat les côtes comme une proue
et les chine comme une brème
vous remarquerez cette tête très sèche
très fine avec une denture une mâchoire
très forte les oreilles en arrière avec
le ce qu'on appelle là le pétale de rose
cette conquête que l'on voit ainsi se
détacher et puis surtout ce qui est
remarquable je crois c'est chez cet
animal c'est cette harmonie cette
harmonie générale de l'ensemble et même
de la démarche qui faisait dire au roi
salomon que avec le cheval et la femme
le lévrier été l'être le plus
remarquable à voir se déplacer avoir
marché les anglais ont travaillé ce
chien vers la fin du siècle dernier pour
le sport et il est vraiment devenu il
s'adonne sa destination de chasse est
parti et il est vraiment devenu un
animal de ce sport est également un
animal d'ornement dans les belles
demeures avec de belle cheminée dont il
est le
le fleuron en général deuxième animal
que nous avons c'est le whippet le
whippet c'est encore une belle réussite
de la cynophilie anglaise c'est un chien
qui a été créée à partir du grès harnes
croisé avec du fox terrier et c'est une
réduction du noble noble lévriers
anglais on l'a un peu on l'a appelé le
lévrier du pauvre parce que c'était un
chien dont se servaient les mineurs de
certains comptes et industriels pour
faire durer ce qu'on appelle le rabbit
coursing c'est à dire de la course qu'on
soit là au lapin c'est ça mais bientôt
on s'est aperçu que ses qualités de
coureur était parfois supérieures aux
qualités de coureur degrés en servir
c'est un chien qui arrivait à tenir à
peu près à 60 à l'heure ce qui est quand
même considérable
mesdames ans sur de courtes distances
mais que de maine et puis ensuite sur
son élégance et son côté pratique en a
fait un chien d'appartement très
remarquée et il faut s'il faut bien il
faut bien signaler que c'est un animal
qui est idéal pour la vie moderne c'est
un hymne à la poêle course à l'animal
qui mesure 44 à 47 cm de hauteur il est
propre il se tient bien partout même à
l'hôtel
et puis il est joueur est gentil avec
les enfants ce qui est souvent une chose
très appréciable lorsqu'on a un chien il
a tout de même cette fidélité cette
indépendance des grands lévriers et en
plus de ça contrairement à ce qu'on
croit ce n'est pas un chien fragile du
tout enfin pour l'appartement il y à
encore mieux peut-être c'est le la
levrette qui est la réduction du lévrier
oui lalanne oeuvrette c'est le petit
lévrier italien où le dre d'italie c'est
une un lévrier mais panne
ce n'est pas un nain c'est un un animal
qui est aussi lent aussi ancien que le
lévrier lui même
on le retrouve aussi bien la cour des
pharaons qu'à la cour des rois de france
on le retrouve dans les alcôves des
plats des patricienne romaine et c'est
annuel qui lui allait nettement plus
petit puisque il fait entre 32 et 38 cm
voilà un chien qui est également
d'asprey d'aspe un peu frêle si vous la
1re rue trembles le temps mais pas du
tout ce sont des animaux les lévriers
sont des animaux robuste et qui même ne
craignent pas le froid
ce ne sont pas des animaux qu'il faut
couvrir auquel il faut mettre un manteau
absolument pas sont des sportifs à nos
docteurs nous
revenir à la vocation actuelle du
lévrier qui est peut-être un animal de
course et je vous propose de
m'accompagner à maisons alfort où nous
avons filmé une course de lévriers il ya
il ya deux types de compétition vous
savez il ya il ya le coursing qui a lieu
sur animal vivant qui évolue à lyon en
pleine nature on lâche de lévriers n'est
ce pas et c'est de lévriers sont suivis
par un juge à cheval il court derrière
un livre vivant et du corps qu'il n'est
pas pratiqué en france n'ont absolument
pas c'est une course anglaise il ya
encore en angleterre quand la waterloo
cup tous les ans qui est très suivi on
juge le chien selon les crochets qui
fait ses rôles yens ils ont évité c'est
souvent la mise la mort bien entendu si
vous voyez on l'aimé on met les chiens
les starting blocks alors là c c'est ce
qu'on appelle le racing c'est à dire la
course en ligne sur lièvre mécanique ou
lièvre électrique les animaux porte des
casaques de couleur avec des numéros et
voilà le leur qui part ça c'est en leur
qualité de la compétition à lui sur une
distance variant entre 350 et 600 m la
sonde et 8 fait le livre étant
maintenues voyant environ à 20 mètres
devant le lévrier peut-être évidemment
c'est une course de vitesse au même site
que les courses de chevaux
en france un seul cynodrome à
fonctionner entre 1935 et 1951 à
courbevoie
mais l'autorisation du pari mutuel de a
été enlevé ça s'est arrêté
mais ça ce sont les grecs qui vont
courir maintenant autorisation a été
rendu puisque on peut parier il a été
rendu mais maintenant on peut on peut
parier actuellement il y à des poignées
dirais-je d'amateurs passionnés qui font
maintenant des courses de lévriers avec
des moyens plus ou moins importants et
je voudrais saluer ici
la tentative que fait le professeur kane
actuellement à l'école vétérinaire de
toulouse de relancer le coursing dans le
sud-ouest de manière très efficace
voyez si vous il faut lui envoyer des
chiens qui jouent même si vous ne vous
ne pouvez pas vous payer de deux chevaux
de course vous pouvez toujours avoir une
écurie de lévriers c'est plus facile à
entretenir c'est moins cher et au moins
vous avez le soir le plaisir d'avoir un
agréable compagnon auprès de vous eh
bien merci pierre rous les blancs des
chiens des lévriers si vous voulez bien
les abonnés quelques instants je vais
vous emmener voir des serpents dans la
fosse à serpents que vient d'ouvrir le
zoo de doué-la-fontaine dans des
carrières naturel c'est un reportage de
nos camarades de la station du mans
[Musique]
le zoo de doué la fontaine est mal
connue du grand public qui et c'est
dommage car ce zoo est unique et au
moins à deux titres
tout d'abord envoyé en ce moment nous
sommes dans une des cinq carrières qui
forment ce zorro et d'autre part dans la
5ème carrière et une exposition safari
serpente vient d'être inauguré monsieur
des vous êtes le directeur du zoo que
vous nous parler de cette carrière sa
femme serpent est bien mais où c'est une
nouvelle création une figuration en
somme nous profitons aujourd'hui du beau
temps pour sortir la plupart de ces gros
serpent mais oui ou que je rassure tout
de suite les téléspectateurs
ce sont des serpents non venimeuse ce
sont des serpents dangereux parce qu'il
ya quand même le poids et la force
un exemple celui ci par exemple mais il
y a aucun venant par la gueule de ces
serpents
alors voici commence je compte faire les
visites c'est l'été avec les
téléspectateurs
nous avons dans cette période qui fait
premiers mètres carrés nous avons tracé
un terrain en forme un circuit en forme
de 8
les visiteurs par cette porte accompagné
de deux rangers armée 2 avant deux en
arrière et nous les faisons marcher
tranquillement au travers de ces
monstres qui font 4 5 et 6 m quand on
constate actuellement il est interdit de
parler interdit de faire des photos en
flash
c'est pour qu'il y ait un jour et pète
danger mais je veille à la quiétude de
ces serpents qui sont en train
actuellement de délimiter leur
territoire
cette innovation est toute nouvelle il
n'a pas encore en france donc lui en
europe ce sont des pépites que je viens
de ramener de malaisie de thaïlande
il s'agit d'un anaconda de
python noirs réticulé de boa
constricteur voici les derniers
pensionnaires et molure view tous des
gros pépère tous des bêtes bien gentil
bien ce blanc alors justement parlez
nous de ces monstres tranquille et bien
il ya pluralité de serpents pour
commencer vous avez des python réticulé
les plus longs et les plus gros
notre ancien fin car c'est bien connu
maintenant si mais glisse 92 kg il ya
des anacondas que j'ai reçue ce matin de
huiyan à 6,15 réticulé subit tout dire
pitau en rose
certains quelques pythons royaux le pull
tiphaine 4 mètre 85 et le plus long
s'ils me disent ces reptiles
vous savez je le devais chercher cette
année en malaisie en thaïlande les voir
sur place les gars facile mais enfin je
peux vous dire que dans pas mal de
maisons de bangkok par exemple de
pennart goût de singapour j'ai vu des
reptiles de deux mètres qui se promène
dans les maisons étant donné que on
mange les chiens on mange les chats il
faut bien les animaux pour détruire la
mer minutes ce sont les gardiens de ces
mesures pente de mètres qui seront même
souhaitable et enfants jouent avec qui a
répète aucun danger
quant à ces reptiles arrive à une
longueur de 3 à 4 mètres sous enfants
les suppléments jour on s'en débarrasse
et comment vous est venue cette idée de
carrière safari sert frau mais a de plus
en plus vous savez que l'on cherche à
mettre des animaux en liberté avec le
cadre ici que je possède il était très
difficile de mettre éléphants au girafon
buffle comme j'essayais derrière parce
que je tiens avant tout à conserver mon
cas d'un cadre naturel ce cadre sauvage
je cherchais depuis un an à mettre des
animaux je cherchais je ne trouvais pas
et celui que j'ai un renom avec une
histoire de serpents l'évasion de kayes
deux ans et j'ai eu l'idée qui tiens si
je pouvais dans un coin dans une
carrière lâcher quelques serpents
peut-être que c'est faisable que les
deux séries est là mais encore fêté le
trouvais serpent alors j'ai donc mûri
cette idée pendant un an peu près j'ai
préparé cette carrière et je suis parti
cet hiver
et là on en malaisie la recherche de ces
de ces serpents j'ai trouvé sur place
quelques petits montages enroulé des
gros alors j'aurais trouvé 5 à singapour
3 penang de à bangkok 4 à hong kong où
j'ai réussi à en ramasser savoir-faire
en trouver comme ça 21
[Musique]
à
les nouveaux livres chez hachette par la
collection continent en couleurs l'asie
par pierre fait faire un continent qui a
fait faire que vous connaissez bien pour
y avoir souvent pour l'un gay pour en
connaître la faune et que vous traitez
deux continents de la démesure pourquoi
et bien des mesures d'abord ne serait ce
que par son immensité puisque le
continent asiatique s'étend sur 45
millions de kilomètres carrés sans
parler des îles qui l'entourent alors
que l'afrique toute entière ne fait que
30 millions de kilomètres carrés et les
deux amériques qui réunit 38 millions de
kilomètres carrés d'autre part des
mesures parce que dans ce continent tout
est à l'échelle de son immensité
c'est en asie qu'on trouve les montagnes
les plus hautes
les malaya chacun le sait c'est en asie
qu'on trouve le lac le plus profond
le lac baïkal c'est en asie également
que s'observe les forêts les plus vastes
les déserts les plus étendus c'est en
asie que par exemple on note le retour
du froid avec moins 70 degrés en hiver
dans la région de verkhoïansk c'est en
asie en 6 et en sibérie
c'est en asie qu'on trouve aussi le
record de la chaleur au pakistan avec
des moyennes de juin qui s'élève à 51
degrés c'est en asie encore qu'on trouve
le record de la pulpe pluviosité dans
l'assam chirac mundi avec dix mètres 2
puis par an parfois 14 m enfin je crois
que vraiment le terme de deux mesures
est plutôt mesurée cette description que
vous venez de faire indique bien que
vous avez cette fois un peu débordé du
cadre et 3 si j'ose dire de la zoologie
oui et non parce que pour moi la
zoologie ce n'est pas l'étude des
spécimens de cabinet ce n'est pas un
fait l'étude des squelettes des animaux
empaillés c'est l'étude de l'animal
vivant et de l'animal vivant non pas
dans une cage mais dans son milieu
naturel autrement dit j'ai été forcément
entraîner a présenté ses milieux
naturels et à décrire la flore là les
paysages et à montrer comment l'animal
ou plutôt les animaux s'intégraient à ce
paysage est souvent l'influent est par
exemple disons la steppe qui est
apparemment eu une étendue morne d'herbe
tout simplement
eh bien on y avait dénombré des
centaines de milliers de rongeurs par
hectare par kilomètre carré et ces
rongeurs forcément influe énormément sur
le paysage lui-même et le façonne en
ramenant l'eau en ramenant la terre de
profondeur de la ramène en surface ça
modifie la végétation et c'est enfin je
ne m'étends pas mais disons que le
milieu est l'animal sont étroitement
liés
vivre est abondamment illustré comment
avez vous pu réunir cette documentation
sur les animaux rares particulièrement
ça il faut reconnaître que ça a été dit
sans la partie la plus difficile du
travail pour trouver des photos car s'il
est facile de trouver des photos
d'animaux africains les girafes lions
etc
il n'en est pas de même en ce qui
concerne l'asie et pour ça alors il m'a
fallu aller en chine en russie prendre
également pas mal de photos moi même et
aussi recourir des photographes le plus
souvent inconnus dans les pays acp xi
occidentaux évidemment tout ça c'était
extrêmement difficile où nantes il ya
quand même c'est un très beau livre que
je vous recommande
jugement je rappelle le titre l'asie par
pierre ferret si vous invite à nous
accompagner dans un autre continent
l'australie qui est tout de même moins
grand mais où nous allons retrouver des
animaux que vous connaissez bien
ce sont des bus le débuff le d'origine
asiatique qui font l'objet en ce moment
d'une espèce de gigantesque opération
capture de la part des australiens cette
séquence est un document il était
tournée dans le grand nord dans le grand
nord australien
ce document va vous faire découvrir les
différentes phases d'une capture une
capture monstre à l'échelle des immenses
territoires que sont ceux de man band et
dans le nord de l'australie
vous le verrez pour commencer on n'a pas
lésiné sur les moyens mécaniques
quant au gibier il est très grand il
s'agit de buffle prend d'un seul mais de
centaines de bus c'est d'ailleurs la
plus vaste opération de ce genre jamais
entreprise en australie
les buffles vivent ici en troupeau à
l'état sauvage au milieu d'arbres ou
leur origine ce sont les premiers colons
australien qui en avaient importé
quelques-uns d'as et depuis près d'un
siècle
ces bulles se sont reproduits sans être
dessiné par les chasseurs
signalons toutefois que cette
reproduction n'a pas posé aux
australiens les mêmes problèmes que ceux
très connu de la multiplication des
lapins qui était devenu comme chacun
sait un véritable fléau
[Musique]
avec le buffle les australiens viennent
de découvrir qu'il y avait là une
industrie d'avenir
la production de viande viande qui
paraît-il est très riche en protéines
sans oublier que les buts peuvent être
employées aux travaux domestiques tout
comme les bovins
mais revenons à notre opération capture
lorsque les observateurs qui survole en
hélicoptère les régions abus on repérait
et localiser les troupeaux il donne par
radio le renseignement aux rabatteurs
motorisés labour suite alors s'engage
elle sera longue et harassante
car la technique employée consiste à
fatiguer les animaux en les poussant
avec des jeeps et des camions
ces véhicules sont spécialement adaptés
à ce genre de travail car il arrive
souvent que l'on rencontre des bêtes
récalcitrante qui ne sont pas décidés à
se laisser faire
lorsque le troupeau exténué consentent à
s'arrêter
il est alors poussé vers des parcages
des enclos installé provisoirement et
hâtivement dans la brousse même
[Musique]
les chevaux avec leurs gardiens prennent
alors la relève des véhicules motorisés
toute une période d'adaptation commence
il faut acclimater les animaux les
habitués à la présence de l'homme
leur apprendre à vivre sur des
territoires plus restreint
c'est la première phase de la
domestication trois semaines s'écoulent
ainsi dans cette atmosphère trois
semaines qui suffisent à l'acclimatation
du but qui contrairement à son homologue
africain est somme toute un animal assez
de 6
[Musique]
le jour arrive où les troupeaux sont
réunis pour être conduits dans l'erreur
la longue marche s'effectue la plupart
du temps sans incidents
accompagnés par des gardians qui n'ont
rien à envier à leurs collègues cow-boys
du far west les troupeaux reprennent la
piste après des journées de marche ils
arriveront à l'endroit de leur élevage
de vastes prairies dont la superficie
atteint pour certaines 12 cents hectares
c'est là que se situera la seconde phase
de la domestication
c'est à dire le dressage
enfin après avoir subi un examen médical
ils verront leurs cornes et pointer et
seront marquées au sigle de leur
propriétaire
et maintenant je vous laisse regarder
quelques images traditionnelles de ce
retour au bercail
[Musique]
où
de cette randonnée les gardians se
trouve souvent une bonne façon
d'améliorer leur ordinaire
en effet tandis que les buffles s'ébroue
dans l'eau la vase du fond de la rivière
remonte en surface entraînant avec elle
de nombreux poissons notamment des
barramundi et des poissons chats
il suffit alors au gardian vous l'avez
vu de leur asséner un coup de gourdin
pour s'en emparer
[Musique]
ainsi grâce à l'apport de ce nouvel
élevage de buffle sauvage
les australiens compte que d'ici 1980
leur parc à bestiaux pourrait atteindre
60 mille têtes
ce qui est loin d'être négligeable
[Musique]